The Joe Rogan experience.
How was it, uh, working with Brian Ortega?
Uh, to be honest, mate, he doesn't say much. He doesn't say much little,
I don't know. Like, yeah, we, we, we I'm, I'm a bit over him to be honest.
<laugh> bit over him. Yeah. Just, uh, a couple of things, you know what I mean?
Like a, I just think he's fake. I think he's, uh,
he's fake and I don't believe you. So that's just sort of how,
how it is with me. That's what I think when.
You say fake, like in what way is he fake?
Oh man. Just, uh, yeah, I just think, you know, he plays,
plays a nice guy and some of the he says, like, I just think it's all, but, uh,
yeah, I guess he can watch the show and like,
sort of see like with little things,
but I know just even with a couple of things, I,
I don't think he's that bad of a guy.
Maybe I'm just looking for things to hate on him for I'm sure you are. Maybe.
Yeah, probably <laugh> you know what I mean? So I'm just sitting there be like,
nah, Brian will take, you know what I mean?
I'm gonna find something to hate him for, but uh, you know,
maybe that's what it was, but I mean like still yeah. Little things.
I was just like, yeah, but I mean, like I said, it's,
it's my hard to get under his skin.
Even me just saying that I guarantee he's boiling up.
So maybe that's gonna be strategy for my next fight cuz I know how easily he's
triggered. So I'm just gonna be like, Hey Brian, you. <laugh> that's it.
When are you, when are you guys scheduled to fight at the end of the series?
Yeah.
Yeah. So where, when it is. Yeah. So, uh, from what I'm told,
I dunno if I'm gonna get in trouble saying this, I'm not sure,
but I think it's like September early.
September, so you'll be fighting him.
So in time in September and that will be in the United States. Uh, yeah,
I'm guessing. Yeah. Yeah. Nice. Interesting. Mm-hmm <affirmative> it's um,
it's a great fight. Like if you look at the fight on paper,
especially after his fight with the Korean zombie, it's fun fight to watch.
Like yeah.
No, he, he definitely, uh, definitely looked good in that fight.
He surprised me in that fight too. He definitely, uh,
changed his game a little bit and fought, uh, a,
a different fight that I wasn't expecting. But uh, but again, you know,
you know, I'm, I'm confident in my abilities. I just,
I just believe I'll be too much. And the Beau the beautiful thing about it,
I can say what I want, but I get to prove it soon. So, you know,
I wish I got to prove it March when I was scheduled a fight,
but obviously that didn't happen. But you know,
I I'll prove that very soon anyway.
So it's all good. It's a special to vision men.
That 1 45 is a really special division, cuz there's so much talent now.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> it's uh, I think it's hard to say what the it's between.
I think it's between 55 and 45,
like the most amount of like real top level talent, but yeah,
45 is just so filled. So filled with guys.
Yeah, there is. Men's a lot of guys that come in,
even some of guys that are higher in the rankings,
like it's just starting to come up. Like there's a lot of dangerous guys.
Oh yeah. And that's what, that's a beautiful thing about it.
Like that motivates me. I'm looking forward to it. You know,
these are the guys I want, I want these guys that are people.
I love being the underdog as well. Yeah. Even though I'm champ,
you're still gonna have their doubters and all that. And I love that.
You know what I mean? I want to be the underdo underdog and you know,
I want them doubters and I love proving people wrong. You.
Like being the underdog.
Yeah. I don't. I do. I do mean that I.
Really do, but do it's gotta be hard to be the underdog when you're the champ.
Yeah. Yeah. It's.
True. I know, but I mean, I guess I wouldn't say underdog,
but I mean the doubt is maybe right. Maybe. Yeah. And I use the doubt as a,
as fuel. Right. So I love, uh, again, I love proving them wrong and my,
if I was an underdog for this fight, you know, I dunno if I would be,
but I mean, if I was, I would not care one bit. I'd be like, right.
At least I get to make my, my boys or whoever's betting on me more money.
Let's go. You know what I mean? So I'm all good. Now.
You guys were supposed to, you were scheduled to fight,
but then you got COVID mm-hmm <affirmative> and when you got COVID,
when you tested initially, when you got tested, you didn't feel sick. Right?
Uh mean before. Cause we got tested a fair bit. Mm-hmm <affirmative> so, uh,
I'm guessing before we went into the bubble,
I must have got it from someone or whatever. And then, uh, you know,
a few days later we got tested a couple of times it didn't pop up,
but then we got tested. Yeah. One of the days.
And that was like right at the end of, of my camp, like,
cause I went there a bit early for Brad Riddell to, to corner or be,
be with him cuz he fought the week before me. So I did my last week of training,
hard training in Vegas after traveling and doing all that.
And then I got COVID uh, must have had it, uh, trained like hard, you know,
we, we get stuck into it. So I did back to back cuz the,
the schedule got tightened up cuz we, we arrived a bit later in the week. So,
uh, back to back really, really solid sessions while I probably had COVID. Uh,
so,
but I mean I sort of had started getting headaches and that before I was like,
man, I'm getting headaches, it's vagus, maybe, you know, just dehydrated and,
and whatnot, but, but yeah. Then test positive.
And then I started getting the symptoms after that.
And when you say like your schedule tightened up,
so you guys have a very rigid program that you follow no matter what,
like this day you're doing this that.
Day. Yeah, exactly. So we got a, you know,
we got a few hard sessions and when I say hard sessions, they're, you know,
they're, you know,
they're mind blowing type of sessions off for some people that,
that will the watcher buddy, you know, that's just our schedule and uh,
usually have good rest in between them and like the that's, you know, you,
you need to have the rest, you know, you want good recovery,
so you are able to do them, you know, and this camp was beautiful. We,
we did it. Absolutely. We nailed the camp, man.
I was doing some of the harder sessions, but I, I was recovering on point.
My recovery was on point. I was like, man, look, you know, I'm getting older,
but I feel like the camp's getting easier. Like how's that happening right now?
But uh, that, that week got tightened.
So I end up doing a couple of these really, really high loaded sessions. Uh,
they end up being like back to back where usually I'd have like high,
low session, high, low would be like.
That decision. What made a decision to do high back to back to back? Uh.
Just, just again, it was just more the fact that, uh, you know,
we just need to do a couple. I, I still don't think was that,
but I felt fine like while I was doing that, like, I didn't think nothing of it,
but I'm just cause I end up getting pretty rattled from, from the,
the COVID that's why I was like, man, like it,
maybe my immune system was down at, you know, at the end of a,
at the end of camp, obviously dieting and all that type of stuff,
but I felt fine, but you know,
I I'm pretty sure I started feeling some of the symptoms, uh, full,
I was getting into them hot sessions.
As well. Yeah. All the fighters that I know that got it bad.
It was all the same sort of situation.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> when they were in camp really beaten up like Cody Garant
same thing with Cody had COVID for probably weeks and was training with it.
Yeah. Before he even got tested and, and then they're like, bro,
you got COVID and he is like, oh, well that explains a lot.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and then, you know, he was pretty up for a few months,
but yeah, he had trained like real hard, like.
Well that's, that's obviously gonna, you know yeah. Play a big factor and you,
and the thing is like you hear, and then you were hear like the hazmat, uh,
you know, sort of situations code Gar mm-hmm <affirmative>.
So like we wanted to keep an eye on it, but you know what I mean?
And that's why we got it. And then they ended up on, oh, you got the pneumonia.
And then, uh, you know, then the symptoms, uh, yeah.
Felt the symptoms a fair bit. But then, uh,
then I got that pneumonia and then like the sort of the infection just started
getting a little bit worser. So I ended up getting you a pink, coughing up,
like pinky bloody sort of stuff. And then the, the just got more and more.
So then we went back and that's when they, they got me on the medication and,
and yeah, cuz I was up coughing up blood and all.
Told how sick, like how long were you sick for?
Uh, probably would've been maybe 10 days or something.
Maybe luckiest days like seven or 10 days.
Did they do IV vitamins or anything like that? Uh, yeah. Once.
Once I was in the hospital, they were doing that. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
as soon as I got on the, the medication, um, you know, for dexamethasone mm-hmm,
<affirmative> like my just improvements like straight away,
but right now obviously I've gotta or take you to worry about and watch this
season and watch everyone can watch me stir him up and give him. So.
What is the pressure like of hanging out with a guy that you're gonna fight for
five weeks? You're just hanging out day in,
day out seeing each other all the time. Well.
We talk about, uh,
I was talking about how I adjust and adapt to things that in front of me,
even in the fight, I'm just like that 24 7, you know what I mean?
I'm the type of guy that whatever I'm doing, that's it I'm me, you know,
I forget I'm a UFC champ. I forget I'm a, I'm a, even a fighter half the time.
You know what I mean? Cuz once I'm home, I'm daddy, that's it. And that's all I,
you know, right. But that's how I am. But I went in there and I just knew, oh,
on a reality TV show, he's gonna be there, whatever. But it was funny cuz again,
you you're trying to get reads on him and, and things like that. But again,
I just think he's awkward. He's an awkward dude. Hey, what do you reckon?
What'd you get outta it? Yeah. That's for.
Sure.
He definitely wasn't a fan of me by the end of the show really actually almost
got fired for one of the pranks. I played on him, but we weren't allowed to, uh,
what was it? You almost got fired or he almost got fired.
I almost got fired for it. Which one was that really? Was that the,
that was the co we had to take five COVID tests a week.
So obviously there's pranks on the show. This won't make the, uh,
TV show anyway, but I did pretend to put his COVID test on my, the mouth, the,
the mouth <laugh> it was a dream. It didn't really happen. But uh, so.
We're pretending to on his like, you know, his signs and all that.
We've got photos of us, like just throwing up again, a bit of laugh,
a bit of banter, but we know how he carries on. There was a photo that he put,
um, you put it up didn't you.
With the keys? Yeah. We pretended to take his car.
Pretend he pretend he had, we just had a photo of the keys and uh,
supposedly he had the, the and like, he was like, oh, oh and fight Craig.
I'm like, I'm in the photo too. Why aren't you saying you'll fight me. Yeah.
He's like, if he touches the car or we'll fight him <laugh>.
But I mean again, like yeah. Whether, whether he was just like, you know,
going along with it or whatever it was, but, or he is just easily triggered. I,
I don't know. But like we, so we started realizing that. So we just,
we just started like playing on that a fair bit. And Hey,
knowing that is easily triggered, there might be a, a route to,
to this next fight.
As well. What happened with the COVID test swap?
Like you took a photo pretending that you were sticking up.
Can we get this up or yeah. Yeah. Um, airdrop it to Jamie, get.
The, get the photo of us out this as well. Or do.
You got the, one of you guys are grown, man. Get the photo of us. Okay.
And the thing with me with the thing up my. Yeah.
Get that MacPro Jamie. Yep. Uh, no MVP.
Oh, there it is. Something happened, uh, right. Okay. But again,
just have a bit of a laugh, you know what I mean? We'll uh,
you know that one or shoot.
It's on the wrong computer. Say the other one. I got this one.
I mean, it's pretty lighthearted, you know,
like I wouldn't really stick his oral. COVID swab at my as.
How could you even get ahold of it? I mean, isn't that stuff controlled.
That's what I don't understand. Like where the is the nurse?
Oh, I just waited to the nurse. Uh, had to go to the bathroom, you know.
Swab. There it goes. Oh my God.
Yeah.
They actually cheeky.
Smirk too. Eh, they actually almost fired me for this one.
So I didn't probably probably crossed the line a little too much. But.
Remember this is a different swap just in case you do.
Still do this is fake ladies and gentlemen. It's.
Just a joke. Allegedly. It might have been a flavored test. You never know.
L O L um, so what did they.
Say to you? Well, I mean, and I did have some ideas for some COVID pranks,
cuz obviously we're trying to get 'em but uh,
they did tell me cuz they spent so much money on COVID testing. They were like,
that's, that's a line we can't cross, but I just couldn't resist.
But Craig did it anyway.
I was just sitting. That's probably not on the film. All.
Our tests were sitting in the same section.
Yeah. I at it <laugh> listen. Makes sense to me. You gotta do what you gotta do,
but it's part of the fun of the show, right? It's with everybody. Yeah, exactly.
The whole, the.
Hope pranks and stuff. Stuff like through each other and.
And the more conflict there is, the better the ratings are.
The better the show does. The better it is for everybody.
When you guys have a big fight mm-hmm <affirmative> catch new is the Joe Rogan
experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog JRE videos on Spotify, including clips,
easily seamlessly switch between video and audio experience
on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save data cost all for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.